a DC Watchdog group has filed to have
Donald Trump removed from the Colorado
ballot and this is just the beginning
it's state number four it's likely going
to continue it's already failed in some
states I don't think there's going to be
tremendous amount of sex for a success
for this strategy but it seems to be
what they'll keep trying to do so we'll
see if that one plays out in the
meantime we've got an announcement on
Hunter Biden's indictment should be
coming at the end of September like it
matters we'll see how that one plays out
it's kind of obvious that most of this
is a foregone conclusion we know they're
going to keep bringing new charges and
new attacks new lawsuits against Donald
Trump and they're going to keep giving a
slap a slap on the rest of Democrats
we've got uh new information Denver's
gonna be paying out millions of dollars
to far left extremists who are riding
yup and of course more j6s are being
criminally charged we'll talk about that
too and the big story tonight of course
I'm sure everybody already checked it
out Tucker Carlson's interview with
Larry Sinclair I'm sure we have a lot to
say about that but I don't know tabloid
stuff so uh let's uh we'll just jump
into it before we get started my friends
how head over to timcast.com and click
timcast irlx Miami to pick up your
tickets to our live event in Miami
October 6th 6 p.m to 10 30 p.m we've got
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr and
Matt Gates co-hosted by me and
lucrakowski of course Ian will be
joining us you can get your tickets now
there's going to be a pre-show there's
going to be an after show q a the after
show will be for those attendants only
we've got a bunch of cool products to
hand out the event is sponsored by
Public Square so there's a bunch of
really cool products from all these
companies that support American values
that are helping build this parallel
economy you're going to get access to
that so we hope to see you there pick up
your tickets at timcast.com but don't
don't forget also to head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member because we're gonna have a
members only uncensored show coming up
for you tonight at about 10 pm
you don't want to miss it it's going to
be fun not so family friendly as per
usual and you as members get to call in
and talk to us and our guest it's going
to be a blast because smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show right now if you really do like
it joining us tonight to talk about this
and so much more as well as pancakes is
Terence Williams thank you for having me
on man uh who are you what do you do so
well first of all I'm a trump supporter
and I stand with President Donald J
Trump and this that's happening to
him right now is disgraceful but uh I'm
a comedian and I started making videos
on social media back in 2016. I blew up
on Facebook and this was before uh Trump
was even the nominee I blew up on
Facebook I was uh talking about I was
addressing some of some of my friends
who were talking about we should move
back to Africa and I said oh hell no oh
oh oh hell to the no I ain't never been
there and I don't plan on going there so
I told them hell no I'm not moving to
Africa I love America I said y'all take
y'all black asses over there I'm staying
right here in America with these white
folks I'm sorry I'm sorry I love my
freedom over here and that video is
super viral and I was eating fried
chicken in the video
it wasn't set up because it was I was I
was on my lunch break it was a lot of
videos my first video and I was
finishing my lunch before I went back to
work and I had some fried chicken with
some macaroni and cheese on this on the
side with some oh some with some mashed
potatoes some country gravy my God I
remember that day but people were so
pissed off while this black man eating
chicken oh Terrence this is Stereo
typical for a black man to be doing this
these white folks is laughing at us I'm
like shut the hell up white people eat
more chicken and black people hell Tim I
try chicken today Tim got a bunch of
chicken
you got all the chickens here I'm
moving in with Tim Tim got all the
chickens but that video is super viral
but but you know and I said some some
the video was it had a lot of sarcasm in
it and people were offended but the
video was about me loving this country
and not wanting to leave and I would and
I didn't understand why people wanted to
leave America when when I saw millions
of people moving here so I just went
super viral and then people ask me well
who are you going to vote for in uh 2016
and I said uh this is before Trump was
even a nominee I said Donald Trump
Donald J Trump and Eric I get all these
comments all your 15 minutes of fame is
up oh it's over with oh you just started
oh you just ended your career before it
even started and then I just doubled
down and people like Terence you kicked
out the black community and from there I
got pissed off and I just started making
videos every day what the hell you mean
I'm kicked out the black community and
just going at it and standing up for the
things that I believe in and I just
didn't unders you know and then and you
know I started doing stand-up comedy and
now I'm a pancake man I got a pancake
company called cousin teas that I
created after yeah they're really good
really good Gourmet
um I created this after they canceled
our sweet dear Aunt jemama they took off
the they took off the shelf they took
away Uncle Ben and what what confused me
was this people people say black people
need more representation and then they
go and take black faces off of food
products so that didn't make any sense
to me and I love pancakes I was like man
I'm not eating it I'm not eating that
bull crap that they have put out they
removed her face that was my favorite
brand so I created so I created cousin
T's and now I mean like I'm in about 38
grocery stores wow in Florida I'm in the
Sedano Supermarket so and and this bread
I came out with cousin T's back in back
in 2021 of of uh of October so it's been
pretty tough getting into the grocery
stores but Sedano's Supermarket gave me
an opportunity a lot of stores don't
want to carry me because they Google me
and they see me in a Maga hat they see
me talking crap offending people and
making jokes and they just don't want it
because they don't want to get counseled
you know so but it's been a blessing and
these pancakes are so damn good we
definitely got to talk about this
because we got a story uh Bill Gates is
buying a bunch of Bud Light stock so
we'll we'll talk about the parallel
economy and and what you're doing and uh
just one last thought man that pulling
Aunt Jemima was really offensive to me
but we'll get into all that I tried some
of your pancakes sorry they're really
good really good so uh thanks for
joining us I should be a lot of fun
thank you we got Brett dasovich hanging
out what's going on I am not moving to
Africa either so I'm I'm staying here
yes my name is I'm the host of Pop
Culture crisis Monday through Friday at
3 P.M Eastern Standard Time right here
on YouTube
right on hi everyone Ian Crossland here
happy to be here Ian crossland.net I
actually think the website's down so
just follow me on X but let's get
started uh you having a matrix attack
Ian maybe I am I'm not sure what
happened uh what's up guys I'm filling
in for search again pressing the buttons
over here my name is Kellen I'm ready to
go when you are Tim let's jump into this
first story they're coming for Trump DC
Watchdog group brings suit on behalf of
Colorado voters to remove Trump from
2024 ballot using the 14th Amendment
that's the gist of the story here we go
again
I don't know if uh it's the citizens for
responsibility nothing's in Washington
crew
claims that Trump has disqualified
himself for violating section three of
the 14th Amendment we knew that they
were trial ballooning this when they
went after a bunch of politicians over
January 6 one guy Coy Griffin out of New
Mexico I think it was actually got
removed over it
I don't know if they succeed
but I do know they're not going to stop
trying to get him removed and they need
to remove him from only one state and it
doesn't even need to be all it has to be
is I don't know how many states are not
winner take all does it feel like
Nebraska is kind of weird but if if they
remove him from any one state
particularly a swing state that's it
he's gonna have a very hard time winning
especially he needs to win three he
doesn't need that many votes you know it
was 42 000 votes he lost by in 2020 but
this is their strategy they can't win
right now we are seeing them go after uh
all of these January Sixers many of many
of whom were non-violent they're trying
to generate as much anti-trump sentiment
we've got new stories about potential
Mass medicaids coming back they are
pulling out all the stops and it is not
even 2024. Charlie Kirk tweeting earlier
that new criminal charges May about may
be about to drop from Jack Smith
pertaining to Donald Trump
and his his uh actions pertaining to
voter machines you've got a warning
already from Jack Smith that Trump's
statements are are tampering with the
jury pool
and it's 2023. we got a whole year in
front of us and the shenanigans have
only just begun I gotta say though I
I just don't I'm kind of resigned to
accept that Trump's not going to be
president and it doesn't matter anyway
because the president ain't going to fix
this it's going to be the private sector
the president can stand by and say no
but cannot make anything happen the
public the public is going to make a
change if we're really going to have
some sort of psychological revolution in
this country it's not going to happen
from the top but the top will be
involved but I don't think placing faith
in the next guy to win the race is like
the way that we're going to save our
nation and it never really was I can I
can I partially agree with what you're
saying it is a cultural shift that needs
to happen and that is happening with the
parallel economy that's being built with
Public Square as successful as they've
been with as we've already mentioned Bud
Light Target we mentioned every single
day and and now cousin T's pancake mix
challenging these World corporations the
parallel economy is the cultural shift
we need to win but in the short term you
know the long-term thing is going to be
winning the culture War the short-term
thing is yeah we're probably going to
need to criminally charge criminals and
have some accountability the idea that
you know I'll put this way Trump winning
is a key is a strategic position in
winning this ongoing cultural cold Civil
War everyone it would be great for a lot
of people but the the metaphor I'm
feeling is like you you're going to a
horse race and trumps your horse for
instance and you're like I that guy he's
gonna win I got everything we need this
horse to win but like they own the arena
where the horse is running they set all
the rules in real time they can have new
Runners come onto the race at any moment
they can actually tell your horse to
stop running and go sit down during the
race so how do you expect that horse to
win
well first of all I want to get
something out the way I was out January
6 I was in Washington DC I was there at
the rally now I did not go to the
Capitol so FBI don't come knocking on my
damn door I did not go to the Capitol uh
but I was there and Trump had nothing to
do with people uh uh busting out windows
or whatever was going on at that Capitol
he did not tell people to Riot Trump
would Trump trump is all about peace
he's all about peace and I was there so
so them going after him for for January
6 is just straight up bogus so I just
want to get it get that out the way
because I was there now
you you are right so we do need a
really listen will things change
probably not but we still need Trump in
office we need him in office and yes the
Democrats and the damn deep state is
running this and running that but we
can't just sit back and say well if
Trump win it doesn't really matter like
that's not the attitude to have what are
you hoping what are you hoping for with
a trump victory
like if Trump wins what what do we what
do you what do you see that well first
of all I want Trump to continue to to do
what he was doing you know he was making
this country great again he had a lot of
stuff in in store for America but also I
want Trump which a lot of people don't
want him to do oh Trump you shouldn't uh
you shouldn't go after them you
shouldn't it that whole retribution
thing is not good Trump should go after
these criminals too he should go after
these people who are causing all of this
chaos in America that's what he needs to
do and if he doesn't win who's going to
go after them I agree we are in the um I
love the politicians are just saying
stuff that they know they can't deliver
on part of the of the election cycle
where and it is as much as I do like
Vivek he's talking about he's like we
need to to ban social media until they
turn 18 I'm like that's unenforceable
you're not going to be able to do that
and that's the the name of the game
right now is telling you that they're
going to deliver on all of these
promises that we know deep down maybe
you get like but they they make 10
campaign promises you get one for ten
yeah for ten but in in the circumstance
let's say Trump says he's gonna do all
he's gonna fire people he's gonna charge
his people he was talking to Glenn Bell
Glenn Beck Glenn Beck said do you go
after these people he's like well you
have no choice based on what they've
been doing it it's really really simple
if Donald Trump gets elected and does
not do it then he will he'll go to
prison for the rest of his life his
supporters will go to prison they'll
start targeting more journalists and
lawyers which they're already doing so
it really is just pick your poison it
either it either it goes one way or the
other there's no middle and there's no
off ramp yeah either if Trump gets
elected and he goes after these people
so it's arresting people you're going to
see arrests he doesn't then they start
they continue what they're already doing
in arresting Trump supporters is lawyers
and they don't stop there I mean trying
to take Trump's name off the ballot is
one of the most extreme things we have
ever seen in this country the first time
I believe it's ever been attempted to be
used and and they're now they're on
they're on a 10 number four right
extreme they silenced the president of
the United States of America that's even
worse when they took him off of Twitter
Facebook Instagram they silenced a
sitting president a sitting president so
I so all the stuff that they're doing
now I am not surprised but we have to
play dirty we have to play the same
games that the Democrats are playing I'm
sick of these weak ass Republicans
sitting back talking about oh well well
we are above that bullsh we're going to
investigate a bunch of stuff and have
nothing come out of any of it yeah yeah
bull crap above my ass we need to we we
we have to play dirty where's Kevin
McCarthy at what is Kevin McCarthy doing
if if people if if this was if Nancy if
people were going after Joe Biden and
trying to arrest him and Nancy Pelosi if
if if uh she was still the the uh
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi will
be knocking doors down right now now
yeah she would not be allowing
Republicans to go after Joe Biden she
would be punching back why are we not
doing the same they're way more ruthless
and with access to the media they come
out looking better than Republicans
every single time but I don't I don't
think that really matters this point I
think more so the issue is everybody
knows that it's a facade but everyone's
just kind of going along with it yeah
it's starting to break though like I was
mentioning I I mentioned these these
four examples two positive two negative
right sound of freedom in Richmond north
of Richmond are huge net positives and
cultural victories and then you have Bud
Light and Target as two examples of
basically
our our side of things does not let it's
not left or right I always you know it's
it's constitutional republic which they
call right or whatever but it could be
you could have more liberal opinions
we're winning in terms of Freedom
Liberty uh challenging the the woke cult
and their and their native control
they're failing look at the ADL and the
splc and the narrative that's come out
as of recently Elon Musk challenges the
ADL now ban ADL goes starts trending on
Twitter yeah X and then what is it the
the executive director guy or whatever
says that they're a bunch of white
supremacists it doesn't work anymore
dude you're just spitting into the wind
at this point nobody cares Jeff to say
it doesn't work we're winning that so so
so let them try their institutional
control is failing this is good news
that's why I'm like you got to be
careful because these videos of j6 just
getting arrested I think is intending to
provoke a response and all you got to do
right now is really simple you got to
buy pancakes right yeah but I'm not even
kidding right supporting the parallel
economy make money for yourself support
companies that believe in your values
get the word out to vote and vote in
large numbers this is why they're trying
to pull Trump's name from the ballot
because they can't win in any standard
circumstance Adrian Norman's really good
about this when he a lot of his uh posts
and the stuff he does with his
journalism is he talks a lot about how
people push back on the cultural issues
online he's like yeah but are you going
out to vote right are you going out are
you actually doing something there's an
old um there's a Sage Francis song from
like 2001 he was super anti-war and he's
basically talking about how his like uh
they complain about the global war but
can't overthrow the local Joker that
they voted for everyone wants to
complain nobody wants to actually go to
The Ballot Box and do something about it
man that that bums me out my experience
with most people in my life when I was
younger I wanted to open uh I knew these
guys had a little miniature Warehouse
with a skate ramp in it and they were
like we all pitching 100 bucks and it
covers the rent and you know we can't
afford it on our own but together and I
was like dude we should do this I go to
my friends and everyone said the same
thing you build it and then I'll think
about it and I was like dude unless we
stand up together right now and
definitively state we will do this thing
it will never happen but that was the
attitude of everyone I knew yeah and
it's similar I I just use it as an
example of how we see most things for a
long time you'd say you've got to get
out go knock on doors ask someone else
will do it let me know when you do it if
I see success I'll consider it nah we
ain't doing that no more Scott Pressler
is out there knocking on doors and doing
the hard work we we here at timcast IRL
maybe maybe we could do more you can
make that argument but I do a Morning
Show and a night show 16 hours every day
talking about trying to build influence
in telling people to to be the change
you want to see in the world for
everyone else it's simple spend time
sending out mailers volunteer do
whatever you have to do register people
to vote and and then we win
well what do you say when people say
Well they're gonna our vote's not gonna
count you got people saying Trump trump
lost by 42 000 votes so when they come
out and they're like there's no way Joe
Biden got 81 million votes I'm like dude
yeah he got 81 million votes because New
York and Los Angeles voted in huge
numbers because they were locked in
their houses yeah but there were three
key swing states where between them
Donald Trump only needed 42 000 votes
that's it they don't have the same
lockdowns anymore people are pissed off
at Joe Biden's approval ratings in the
gutter if Trump supporters quadruple
their efforts not even if Trump
supporters just stick to their efforts
Joe Biden's vote count is going to go
down exactly you double your efforts
Trump's going to win by a healthy amount
do you think that they're that the
reason why we're starting to see all the
Articles come out again about Mass
mandates is that they're looking to rein
to reinstate any type of lockdowns
before the election yes they're looking
to steal the election they're doing the
um
yes removing Trump for the ballot is
cheating they're going to use the
mail-in balance to cheat but that but
see but it's not going to work this time
because a lot of Americans are not going
to stay in their homes they're not going
to put on those masks a lot and I'm
talking about people on both sides are
not going to do that so they need to so
they need to put so that's why they want
to put president Trump in prison that's
why they want to lock them up because
they can't use coven to win this time
it's not going to work they're already
nobody's falling for that they're
already doing it with like um when it
was in 29 teen it was Tom Hanks was the
first celebrity to get covered and
they're like oh my God if a celebrity
can get covered then I suppose I can
they're already doing this again where
they're reading like because I I cover
pop culture and news like that so I'm
seeing all these articles like celebrity
gets this celebrity so they're already
saying like uh Whoopi Goldberg gets
covered for the third time and
everybody's shocked but it's because
they're already starting to roll out the
article propaganda when they start
trying to reinstate these things let's
let's do a little tip for tab we'll jump
to the other side now we have this from
the post millennial special counsel
David Weiss expected to deliver Hunter
Biden indictment by September 29th why
said Hunter Biden faces firearm related
charges as well as two counts of tax
fraud now I wonder about these stories
because of course we want accountability
for corrupt individuals we know that Joe
Biden was involved this could be a first
step that leads to an impeachment of Joe
Biden but I kind of feel like they are
going to find a way to give this dude a
slap on the wrist right so you got a
couple stories one right now you got
January Sixers being given these harsh
penalties years and present decades in
prison and Ricky tario wasn't even there
and then you get stories like this
Denver to pay 4.7 million dollars to
settle claims that targeted George Floyd
protesters so it's absolutely
fascinating insane yeah the the left
goes out in riots across the country 30
plus dead and multiple jurisdictions are
paying them I think the total so far is
like 100 million dollars so we may be
seeing the charges of Hunter Biden but
as you were just mentioning yeah where's
Kevin McCarthy where are the Republicans
where is he at where's that they never
they never do anything it's it is the
most frustrating part of it right when
you when you pay that close attention
and you're wondering why is it that it
seems like they're constantly like
Democrats left they
they make territory they get good
territory all the time they're always
able to do that but for some reason the
Republicans never do it because the
Republicans are just Democrats going the
speed limit if not slower because they
don't actually want to make any changes
and the Republican party is divided if
you if you look at the Democrats even
listen some of them probably don't like
Joe Biden but they but you will never
know they're not going to speak out
against Joe they're all gonna they're
all gonna be on they're all going to act
like they're on the same page you know
Joe Biden's a good president now here
you got the Republicans divided you got
this you got you got half of them
attacking Trump half of them saying less
less uh let's uh stand behind Trump when
we need all of them to be standing
behind and even when Trump was even when
Trump was the president the Republican
party was divided you know was there was
there numbers on the amount I think we
covered this at some point right there
there was numbers on the amount of
people that said if they had known about
the hunter Biden laptop Scandal before
the election it's like seven to eight
percent seven eight percent like I was
talking to someone recently so they
don't even think that they think that
the Republicans or them going after
Hunter Biden's a losing plan anyways
like they they don't feel like it
actually moves the needle enough enough
to make it worth it other than if you're
actually acting on principle and doing
it because you actually want to right
prosecute somebody that's committing a
crime I don't completely disagree I
think that going after Hunter Biden is
not necessarily an election issue it's
an accountability issue but it does lead
to the business dealings of Joe Biden
who is now it's being reported using
what Alias is to communicate with Hunter
to give him private information because
he was using Hunter as a proxy to
conduct a business well as VP and this
is this is this is part of the news
that's coming out which could be the
hunter Biden indictments could be the
lead up to the impeachment of Joe Biden
it'll give them more Authority we'll see
what happens I I I I really don't want
to give the Republicans the benefit of
the doubt
I don't believe they'll do things part
of me says maybe they're gonna slow roll
it until the election year you'd rather
have an October surprise than a year
early October announcement that's not a
surprise for anybody give them a year in
advance to deal with and that's an
attorney
eternity in an election you want to come
out the damaging information right as
early voting starts then people don't
vote and have an impact so maybe that's
when they try and do it I don't know
will it even matter anyways because the
media will just suppress it but but we
are the media right and so looking
looking at CNN's ratings in the trash
can and now Fox news ratings are in the
trash can it's actually going to be the
likes of uh Joe Rogan Russell Brand
Patrick David Tim cast IRL Jimmy Dore
more and more people are consuming
information through these platforms
which is exactly why for instance Bud
Light sees a massive derailing of their
of their stock value
look our our the younger generation grew
up consuming media in this way I don't
think any show ever reaches the level of
Tucker Carlson
back you know uh 10 20 years ago you had
very few channels so everybody watched
very similar things there's there's pros
and there's cons to that the benefit is
that most people uh or I should say
there is a benefit in people being on
the same page in terms of facts if the
facts being given uh given out are
correct but then you end up with
intelligence agency influence and lies
and then everyone believes lies the
internet allows people to challenge the
machine fact check prove it provide
evidence check sources now the the
there's a negative in that sense that
you know like a show like this like
Tucker Carlson was getting three to five
million every night I don't think anyone
ever gets that big ever again
right we get like a tenth of that and to
be fair the majority of those those
viewers are older because they were used
to watching this these older networks
but now that you have a diversified
group of citizens getting you know
different like this the correct
information but from different
perspectives like all the podcasts I
mentioned
it's hard to break that it's hard to lie
to a group of people that have all these
different sources because you can't
Mockingbird this it's easy when you got
four four networks and the CIA or the
FBI or whatever they say look for
national security reasons don't report
this story and they all agree when it
came to the NSA files the um
this was the Snowden stuff you have uh I
don't know let's I think the the uh
there's a bunch of different
whistleblower examples and you have um
what movie was it I think the Julian
Assange one these news outlets are like
what do we do with these releases we
have to be careful let's ask the US
government about it that don't matter
anymore because now if intelligence
agencies want to try and pull a
Mockingbird good luck reaching out to 10
000 podcasts you can't do what they'll
do the next generation of Mockingbird is
they'll deep fake someone that's
respected like Patrick Bet David they'll
deep fake him saying something that
isn't true so it's like a reverse
mocking bro instead of trying to give
you the false information they're going
to trick you into believing it they'll
try it and then it'll also they they
can't do that but David they can try and
defame someone like you know any one of
these podcast hosts but Patrick but
David's audience trusts him they know
him he'll come out and say that's not
true guys and people are going to
believe him they could try to create a
fake Channel where they come out with a
with a pro like a prop personality but
they're not going to get enough reach
what they could do is they can go to the
parent platform let's say there's a
large sales network called like
your TV and on your TV they create rules
that defy logic that go against doctors
uh and medical science but adhere to
political instructions and then they ban
anyone who goes against it that's the
best they can do the only problem is the
market will solve for this then you're
going to end up with I don't know
there'll be some alternative called like
fumble or something yeah that will
actually shout out to rumble Rumble
emerges and then outright says not only
are you allowed your Free Speech but we
will create an ad Network to support you
and they're getting there here's I'll
give you guys some interesting
information we the live shows here on
YouTube but we put all our Clips on
everything on Rumble as if it's any
other platform and we get on my morning
show I get like 30 000 views on average
I get about 180 to 200 depending on the
video on YouTube and I'm getting about
30 000 on Rumble Tim cast IRL Clips
actually are rivaled on Rumble this is
the fascinating thing we might put up a
clip on YouTube from this show that gets
200 000. every so often we'll have a big
clip like that and then periodically
we'll get 50 to maybe 90. on Rumble we
get 50 to 100 000 views on these clips
Rumble Rumble is
stripping away market value from YouTube
and YouTube too stupid to realize it
yeah they are yeah so I have a new
podcast how it's called the Terence K
Williams podcast
um it took me a long time to come up
with that name
but now this is embarrassing but the
podcast is new and my the average vid
the average that the average episode
gets 5 000 views on YouTube I posted one
up I posted an episode with me and Dean
Kane on Rumble it got a hundred thousand
views I'm like what in the world
Superman first Rumble rumble's audience
are many of the refugees from these
platforms so you will find and people
who are more into politics you're going
to have a uh that that's there's going
to be a huge market share a huge
Advantage there but with Rumble getting
into sports yo I was watching a skate
video skateboarding listen to this
because most people I don't care about
skateboarding no no pro skateboarders
and the private skate park to all of
their 16 17 year old viewers Rumble
Sports on the wall and I'm like that's
it Rumble Sports sounds good yup main
Rumble Sports mainstream branding in
mainstream pop culture that kids are
going to watch and when they go to
rumble to watch their Sports and video
games they got Terence Williams right
there yep you know what Trump does need
to do though if he's if we're talking
mainstream he needs to just like whine
and dine the ladies from the view
because he really does struggle with you
know if we're talking like Suburban
women he's not the most liked person he
needs to just whine and dine the ladies
from the view and really get them to
turn around been on The View do you
think do you remember it was on The View
and he was asked to run for president oh
yeah I think Roseanne asked yeah they
used to
of Oprah asking him when he was going to
run for president but I have to fact
check you the women on The View those
ladies they are not Suburban women
yeah but they speak because they speak
to Suburban their Their audience is
Suburban women at home oh the other day
when Joy Behar was like it's back and I
was like so cringe cringe yeah but
Whoopi won't be here like that 27 during
their 27th season which is insane but
why are they not adhering to the writers
and actor striking but are people really
don't even know what they're talking
about yeah are women are people really
watching The View yes they they affected
yes I do I absolutely believe that they
affect the Suburban female voting
demographics big time because they're
not they're not like the the stats say
that men watch YouTube more than women
right if I remember correctly so if a
woman is watching terrestrial television
she's going to be watching something
she's cleaning during the day she's
she's getting your kids Lunch is ready
she's watching The View and she's seeing
a bunch of spewed you know deep State
propaganda being you know fed back to
her and that's the voting block that's
going to end up costing you election if
you can't swing at least some of the
female demographic I don't think that
there's money their ratings are way down
way way way way down but they're still
getting between like 1.82 million view
viewers but it just it Cycles through so
one so one lady watches it and she goes
to her knitting group of of women and
they talk about what she talked about on
the episode that day and it permeates
more naturally right it's not that they
all watch it they also when you see that
stuff you don't talk about like they get
clips clips get posted on social media
there's more than just the live numbers
that affect how far someone's reaches on
a lot of these platforms
so yeah I I just don't think there's
nothing that Trump can do to satisfy
those women not at all there is nothing
but but yeah and if Trump went on their
show the whole show will be a gotcha
show but you need to consider too yeah
it's not even necessarily about Trump
convincing them to vote for him it's
about the Republicans in general
convincing Democrats not to support Joe
Biden right so and it's funny because
the Democrats are going to be like oh
Tim Poole's saying people should not
vote no like no I'm saying vote for
somebody else yeah but like Joe Biden's
not going to give you anything he's just
going to keep doing garbled nonsense war
in Europe you want World War III vote
for Joe Biden you want a crippled
economy vote for Joe Biden I'm not even
gonna I won't even say this I'm not
gonna tell you right now to vote for
Trump I'm saying don't vote for Biden
you know if you want social justice then
you vote for uh Cornell West right he's
your he's your leftist Progressive guy
you want uh The Establishment to get a
stake through its vampiric heart uh you
vote for Donald Trump and that's not
even a guarantee it actually happens but
it's the best shot you've gotten do you
think Vivek Just Too Young Too new to
actually have a chance at winning the
presidency yes it's it's winning the
presidency is more than just being like
playing the game properly the the
reality to Vivek is that it's he he
would need to to make
every perfect step which he is doing
with very few mistakes
uh he would need to make every move
perfectly and hit every die roll
perfectly yeah he would need the Deep
state to prop him up that's what Obama
had that's why he went from obscurity to
fame so I mean sure that would help I'm
not saying that I'm saying he doesn't
need there are certain things you can do
in your campaign that you can do right
or wrong needs to roll like three
twenties in a row yes that's tough
because no money on Trump trump has the
base Trump has a great track record with
the economy and with a lot of a lot of
issues that's so famous well he's super
famous but but you look at foreign
policy Abraham Accords you look at uh
the attempts at peace deals outside of
that you look at uh timeline for
withdrawal from Afghanistan which Joe
Biden screwed up but I mean mostly for
Americans gas prices were low the
economy was great then covet hit it's
hard to blame him just for that because
under Biden you also had the covet went
from Trump and through Biden so they
both get hit on that point Trump could
have done things a lot better but
Trump's got a track record people like
like you were saying you want to see
Trump keep doing these things you know
he getting rid of the TPP one of the
first things he did bolstering U.S
manufacturing bringing auto
manufacturing back to the Rust Belt the
attempts to secure our border far from
perfect but heavy efforts being made
people like these things the the best
numbers of Our Lives Jim Cramer said
that Jim Cramer was always wrong with
celebrating how great the economy was so
on that alone I think Donald Trump is
beating up Vivek
Vivek has to get lucky
and there's a lot that would have to
happen for him to actually win so you
can be the best guy for the job and I
think Vivek in many ways is
but because of the problems we've we
face in terms of corruption
Vivek may not be
he may not be the right person
like he speaks he speaks well he plays
politics very well he's got great policy
ideas he fleshes them out he addresses a
lot of issues we want to see addressed
but there's there's that fire that I
don't know that he actually has that
Trump does have because Trump was
personally slighted you know what I mean
yeah I don't see people rallying behind
the vague it's harder yeah and his name
is kind of hard to pronounce too in the
beginning everybody gets a name wrong
yeah it's a challenge for him that's not
presidential it's just not sure
so what do y'all think about Rhonda
Sanchez if Trump is not the nominee you
think he can beat Joe Biden uh yes I
could beat Joe Biden I think to say do
you think he has a better chance than
beating Joe Biden no then who then Trump
then president Trump not if it was on
the board but I feel like there's so
much back behind the scenes crap against
Trump that it's like and this one really
bums me out because a year ago I've said
hands down no question but then we got
to watch how DeSantis ran his campaign
yeah and now I'm just like no he I think
DeSantis would could beat Biden because
he's he's less unlikable yeah right he's
just kind of there yeah but Biden is
unlikable his age is a problem you've
got a quarter of Democrats saying that
they can't vote for him he's too old and
then you get Ron DeSantis who would just
be there and I think that should be
enough he would effectively be Biden to
Biden right Joe Biden was the corporeal
form Democrats asked for nobody really
wanted to vote for Biden they just
wanted to vote against Trump well you're
gonna get a lot of people who would
support DeSantis a lot of people
begrudgingly would support his handis
and then a lot of people people would
just blindly back and it's better than
Biden yeah Donald Trump however would
rally people he would so I I I I think I
think DeSantis could have been it if if
DeSantis ran the campaign that Vivek is
running he would be ahead of Vivek right
now do you think that because I saw
Chuck Todd interview Vivek I think the
Vic's been on he's been on some of like
the leftist mass media Legacy Media
stuff is it because they're attempting
to split the party in half for the
voters so that the Democrats win
say one more time why would they would
prop the vake up and just go like Chuck
Todd's really seems to like him and want
him on his show and interview him like
are they just trying to create a
division in the Republican party so
there's going to be a nominee I mean Ron
DeSantis is already doing that right so
they so they don't need to use uh Vivek
for see his name I can't even pronounce
his damn name but but yeah the vague is
more is more likely
I told this to him I was like I don't
think you're gonna win and I think you
know you're not gonna win right like no
one as smart as that guy joins us race
being like I can beat Trump no you can't
you cannot defeat Donald Trump in this
primary
so Vivek is playing it masterfully he's
supporting Trump while running against
him it's brilliant I would love to see
him in Trump's cabinet he said I would
love to see him in his cabinet he said
he didn't want to be a vice president
though right you did right he told me
that yeah but he has to say that so
we'll see he has to say that because
he's running for a president but hey
yeah he just cast Trump Rama Swami would
be a powerful ticket because that really
would be because Vivek is playing the
game perfectly but he's not in a
presidential position and he's the guy
that you don't want if I'm speaking from
the deep State's perspective who's like
afraid they're going to lose their jobs
you don't want Vivek to become the
president because he'll fire you he will
terminate your job so those people are
like yo we don't if he's the VP you will
make sure that President stays in power
because you do not Vivek stepping in
ending a bunch of the corruption
I'm just imagining it and I just know
it's never going to play like this but
you know the Trump gets elected Vivek is
the VP and then you know they walk into
the Oval Office they sit down Trump
looks up and he goes
do it and then Vivek stands up buttons
his jacket walks out of the hall and
then makes the Fallen call and then
they're all fired that's the thing if
evict did serve as vice president I
think it could be a lot more of a a
front-facing public role than Pence did
Pence was like behind the scenes quiet
Meek yeah exactly to fix a loud guy like
he loves to talk in front of crowds and
stuff and he can rally the people he can
explain complicated things technically
to the American people
he would he would serve as an excellent
translator for Trump's weird like
Trump's like build a wall and it was
like why he didn't explain the Chinese
are running our fentanyl through the
southern border I thought it was a
xenophobic move at first I thought he
hated the central Americans I thought he
was like we don't want those people here
it was the drugs it's the drug cartels
running human trafficking if that had
been the message early on I don't think
he would have pissed off all those
people I think Trump did say that he
said they're bringing drugs into our
country but it doesn't matter because
the media doesn't report on it and they
clip it all out anyway but I don't care
about the media anymore but that's what
you do yeah none is is getting a like
they're struggling to reach six-figure
audiences but the back then it mattered
oh no for sure but today it's now it's
just like let the media not report it I
don't care anymore we put out we put out
one clip on on this channel and it beats
CNN's entire Prime Time ratings in the
key demo CNN's getting like 40K they are
not influential with young people
anymore the way that's done media has
changed the definition into what we're
doing right now is we are the media it's
like frogs in a pot like I didn't
realize I could sense in 2006 that it
was happening and I would say we are the
media now just to manifest it and make
it happen sooner but like to be in it
for 15 years I didn't it's hard to see
the change but look look but we are it
this is it it's actually really really
simple to understand how these things
happen
when I'm younger I'm looking at CNN Fox
News ABC and I'm looking at all these
they're getting millions of views I'm
like wow that's crazy and then me and
all my friends are hanging out doing our
thing
that thing that we are doing is it when
we're older and these anchors have all
retired we didn't change what we did we
kept doing the same thing yeah so you
you just inherit it because you're doing
it it wasn't that one day there was like
a switch was flicked no it's just
younger people even today right now with
like Tick Tock and other social media
platforms short form uh YouTube it's why
YouTube is rolling out shorts
we like Millennials watch shows like
this younger people are consuming
shorter Clips they're but you know
that's why they're investing in
influencers exactly yeah I want to jump
to this story uh and go back to what
we're talking about with uh political
conflict with this from timcast.com
Liberty Safe cites company protocol on
decision to provide FBI with access code
let me slow down this is about the
January 6 cases for those that aren't
familiar a guy was arrested
he had a Liberty Safe a gun safe
Liberty was contacted by the FBI who
said we have a warrant for his premises
so they gave the code to the safe to the
FBI now there's a lot of questions that
arise from this
how did they have the code to the safe
in the first place
easy it appears that Liberty has
publicly admitted as a safe company they
have a back door to all of your safes
this means if you own a liberty safe for
your guns you are compromised
period This is not political this is not
I don't like the company because they
betrayed a guy or whatever look I'll
tell you this right now
if a company receives a court order to
hand over information I fully expect you
to do it we are a nation of due process
and laws and if a judge signs off on a
legitimate warrant or court order saying
you're going to turn this information
over we expected it to happen when we
subpoena the doj or whatever when the
Republicans do when the in Congress and
they don't do it we get mad about it if
a court order is given down we respect
it now there's a bunch of questions here
Liberty apparently didn't get a court
order they were shown a warrant for
someone else's house and then said sure
we'll give you we'll give you the code
anyway that's got a lot of people pissed
off but more importantly outside of all
the politics if you purchased a Liberty
Safe understand that at any point for
any reason legal or illegal someone else
has access to your safe and could steal
everything you own and I'll give you a
simple scenario
Liberty has a back door baked into your
safe that means someone has access to
that code I assume it's likely based on
an algorithm pertaining to the serial
number of your safe this is typically
how companies generate unique passcodes
and back doors I don't know that this is
exactly how they do it but we do know
they have the code which means a rogue
employee could see an order comes in for
a high-end say for thousands of dollars
which can hold 50 Grand in guns and
other equipment or who knows what gold
and then tells one of their buddies hey
here's the address here's the save model
and here's the backdoor code they wait
six months monitor your home because
they know your address because the guy's
got it
now I'm not saying Liberty employees are
compromised I'm just saying why would
you risk it more importantly anyone
could steal the information from Liberty
and now they can break into your safe
this is this is a great the craziest
thing to come out uh in terms of uh you
know the one of the craziest stories so
far
Liberty Safe issued a statement saying
that uh it's their policy to give access
codes to law enforcement if a warrant
grants them access to a property what
that means is
a court order was not issued to the gun
safe manufacturer they just showed them
that they have a a warrant for the
property Liberty Safe could have said
when a judge instructor instructs us to
hand over the information we'll do it
but we can't until then and even if they
do they can say our lawyer will appeal
this is absolutely insane to find out
this is resulting in a major backlash I
don't know how big Liberty is but I just
want to stress to you guys if you own a
Liberty Safe you are compromised the
same thing hold true for home alarm
systems
it look typically
when it comes to uh the answer is yes
when it comes to security we don't
expect them to install backdoor access
to our our our systems that we we buy
right so so let me show you this I have
another I have another tweet people are
already pointing out this is secure it
gun storage they responded saying we
firmly believe in our customers right in
Freedom to control their personal
property recently secure it was made
aware made aware of and asked to comment
on the situation involving the FBI in a
well-known safe manufacturer the FBI
requested the access code to the safe of
an individual for whom they have a
warrant to search their property the
company protocol is to provide these
access codes to law enforcement if a
warrant grants acts that grants them
access to the property it is secure its
belief in protocol that the protection
of personal property in the second
amendment rights of American citizens
are Paramount our full line of Fast
Access modular safes are not built with
any override systems giving our
customers full control the freedom and
liberty to possess Firearms is the right
of every American citizen secure it will
always put those same rights of our
current and future customers first that
is to say based on the information
before us if you have a Liberty Safe you
don't know who has the backdoor code
that means
more than just you can go into your safe
maybe you've got your dad's watch your
grandmother's necklace or maybe you've
got a twenty thousand dollar brand new
beautiful Barrett of some sort so with
with tons of ammo and it's yours and
it's expensive and you don't want it
stolen why would you go with a safe
company that runs a back door the
interesting thing is I'm not seeing
in the leftist media direct attacks and
insults like you normally expect from a
story like this why the left has
consistently complained about companies
creating backdoor access to encryption
so it's going to be very difficult for
them to come out and be like haha gun
nuts are losing their uh-oh yeah we
actually don't like that idea either
especially many of these leftists who
are pro-gun so if you have a secure it
safe and the and the FEDS or anyone goes
to them they're going to say look we
don't have access that is a private safe
owned by somebody you got to figure it
out for yourself man I have no idea
Liberty's like don't worry we installed
backdoor access to all of our safes and
we'll give it to you if you ask right I
mean they can they could have some mad
employee to sell the back door access to
someone you you never know the fact that
they even got that is is ridiculous
Apple didn't turn over information back
in 2013 right I imagine all of them
would now this this is really really
crazy too if you look at you know uh I
think I think Apple did turn up with
some information well there was a big
story where the feds demanded Apple open
a phone and they were like no way yeah
yeah because here's the thing that's
what I'm saying leftists are very very
angry about backdoor access because you
know they do creepy stuff they have
activist servers they don't want the FED
seizing they don't want so Apple's
probably thinking like if word gets out
that we give the feds access to your
device we're gonna lose a lot of money
in market share so just don't do it
unless you absolutely have to
good luck Liberty Safe I guess this is a
big part of the reason why uh as a
social network and just in general you
don't want to hold more data than you
need because then you become a
vulnerability like mines uh doesn't have
uh
you know chat Keys we don't have access
to the chat at Minds because uh it's
encrypted and it's user to user like if
you have the keys then when the FBI
comes that you have to give them to the
FBI legally you're off you're expected
to do it uh it's better not to hold the
data I would say immediately get rid of
your Liberty Safe if you've got one to
get a new safe that doesn't have a back
door in it because that is massive
vulnerability so someone could steal
your gun out of there and and use it to
commit a crime and make dude make it
look like you did it there's so much
there's so much wrong with this uh I
would argue that they are not secure at
all if a back door is installed someone
could figure out all right so I don't I
don't know exactly how they generate
backdoor passcodes it could be the
stupidest thing in the world where
Liberty Safe has a master code for all
saves is identical which would be insane
for all I know they're then one two
three four I mean yo they they used to
do this uh without me naming the system
itself there were very common machines
that were available to the public
everywhere and their their unlock code
was based it was like 54321 and they
just figured nobody would know how to
access the panel to do it and then on
the internet they were like hey guys
here's how you can access the the the
the control systems for these widely
available machines I'll keep it simple
they were vending machines but I'm not
gonna say which ones and people started
changing prices and doing crazy crazy
stuff and it was like they didn't expect
it to happen and then after people
caught on they said guys change the
default code on these machines but
as Ian was pointing out imagine somebody
uh let's let's imagine two scenarios One
Liberty uses a default master code it's
16 digits and it can open any safe okay
you're compromised beyond belief anyone
can just go in and do this
now imagine they don't do that but
what a lot of companies do let's say
routers
the router will have a serial number
they have an algorithm which creates an
a passcode based on the serial number of
the of the router if you don't know the
algorithm you don't get the password
however activists in Spain
took a whole bunch of passwords they
knew and a whole bunch of serial numbers
and then ran it basically through an
algorithm to determine what the
encryption was and from that point on
when I was in Spain they they had an app
for this that they made we're sharing
you could if the if the default name of
the device was still available and it
would say like you know mobile router
78391 a62 it would instantly generate
the passcode based on the default name
of the router
the same thing could be true for Liberty
Safes someone could break into the house
with an app take a p type in the serial
number and then it auto generates the
backdoor access key these things are
worthless hunks of garbage I think there
should be a massive lawsuit I think
there should be a class action suit I
think anybody who has one of these
things should get a refund on it I I
don't know I don't it's crazy to hear
this and they're saying it's their
policy if you bought this and they
didn't disclose that there's actually
backdoor access you got they they robbed
you yeah oh I imagine now do they have
do every company like this have to uh uh
like do they have to inform you that
they have backdoor access I don't think
so I mean you buyer beware if you if you
you know right like if you sell the
product there are some things you have
to disclose and some things you don't
you know in California if you're selling
food you gotta say it's got carcinogens
in it but some things you don't have to
well maybe this should be something that
people have to do that these companies
have to do you'll need a federal law for
that good luck getting that passed yeah
that's that's tough the federal
government is Lodge it's a good point
yeah
if they didn't know they were getting
sold a machine with a back door uh
that's that's scandalous yeah and I
think the FBI already knew before they
even called uh whatever what is this
what is it called Liberty Safe yeah
Liberty Safe they already knew
the FBI already knew or they wouldn't
have called them exactly they knew
consider
the fact that the FBI contacted them and
said can you give us the back door key
that's crazy man
absolutely gradients do they make you
guys know Liberty I don't know we'll
Google it how ubiquitous is this company
right now gun sales and maybe this is
something that that Trump should I know
you said it's going to be hard you know
getting something like uh uh getting
something passed to where these
companies have to inform the buyers that
they have you know backdoor access
but why not let them know like
why not why should they wait why why
would the I mean why shouldn't they know
when you move into a house you change
your locks yeah you're moving to a new
apartment you change your locks would
you buy a deadbolt for your house if the
package said and a random guy you don't
know also has a copy of your key hell no
you'd be like what I don't know out of
here dude hell no but but at the end of
the day I want to know I want to know
and I think I should know that yeah
because because it's my safety you could
have some mad crazy insane employee who
could you
there's like you can go to a Home Depot
and get a copy of your key made but
who's to say that they didn't just make
an extra copy for themselves right
that's true
what a it's not a yeah that that is very
true not that they know what your key is
for necessarily but well they have a
copy
because they made you a copy so so they
have the digital print for it you know
but they might not know what it's for
he's saying right like what what's the
key for even yeah hopefully not
I mean I imagine like if you're buying
something like this it has some type of
um manual on how to use it and it's
probably buried in the fine print in the
back of the manual that the that the
access would be given up if need be yeah
if you forget your code you can always
use zero zeros you know whatever the
hell is some people say you know I've
been some people say and after this came
out a lot of people are saying we just
don't have privacy at all really like
there's no such thing as real privacy in
this country dude there's there's
satellites that can like track your the
noise you're making I don't know the
technology exactly but they said that
there's like they can put like a I don't
know if it's a radio frequency or
something through your walls in your
house and then listen through listen to
you through your through your walls like
what the I kind of tend to agree that
privacy is gone like I think we can go
out in the woods and have a really quiet
conference like this but who's to say
that the the satellites aren't picking
it up at this point I don't know I don't
feel like anything's private these days
I got Alexa on in the freaking listening
my phone if you say Okay Google it
Sparks this stupid thing don't say it I
just did and it's like how innocuous is
that that three words can trigger
millions of devices to go off and then
it's like your your phone says like if
you uh if you would like us to not have
access hit this button like I'm sure
you're absolutely listening to this I'm
sure you're I'm sure you followed the
letter of the law which should be off by
default my God that should be off by
default someone super chatted saying
that it was a Public Square company
let's pull it up
uh wasn't there a story about like
Zuckerberg's wound got hacked once in
his password was like d-a-d-a well I saw
a commercial with Sean Hannity promoting
uh the safe coming yeah the Safe Company
really yeah there's a big deal yeah
I mean they're gonna have to just remove
it yeah they can't Let's uh let's search
it
Liberty
TNT Liberty Safe sounds at the same
company is it different company
people register their safer yeah no this
is a different company
this is very much a different company
guys
this is TNT
so that's good to find out unless I'm
wrong but I'm pretty sure it's a
different company
this uh the other the other company is
uh
let me see I'm I'm searching for it
the Liberty States we're talking about
is based out of Utah this one said TNT
so let's not say a word yeah it's
different okay I'm pretty sure it's a
different company so there's more than
one Liberty Safe Company
yeah this one's just Liberty and then
it's a safe really small underneath it
yeah yeah that you're thinking of
something different we do not besmirch
the good name of of a separate company
that did nothing wrong uh look I got if
if Liberty saves comes out and says
we're abandoning this policy we are
revoking all back door access it will be
none of our models we can we'll have
this anymore I'd be like okay awesome
that's fantastic thank you and that's it
and then buy their saves but in the
meantime oh dude I'd say uh if you have
a Liberty Safe dude holy crap I believe
the government has access to everything
everyone else does like you can't trust
a government agent not to tell your
buddy down the street you can't your
past your safe password so the next time
he's over having dinner
you can just go into your bedroom and
like what well of course you gotta
obviously that's like a string of crazy
events but it's possible but look look
you you you've got spare keys to your
apartment or your house and a neighbor
has them in case of emergencies but it's
because you trust your neighbor like
like I said imagine if you went to the
hardware store and it said quadruple
ultimate level 27 Ultra lock and the key
is like this weird long snake thing with
all these spikes on it you can't even
understand you're like wow and it's like
plus with every order a key is given to
a random guy you've never met you'd be
like
what bill and security has a copy in
case you in case you lose yours and
he'll come over and you can totally our
our company has a has a secret key to
all the locks we sell and we you know
and we're going to give it to whoever we
feel like deserves it without a court
order so a locksmith can't a locksmith
came to my house he changed out all the
locks in my home and he was like man I
just gotta tell you I love you I'm a big
fan and
I appreciated that that he was a fan but
I was uncomfortable because you don't
say anything that makes God knows me
like he's gonna go he's like can't wait
to tell my wife and
cousin
and I don't know
he's probably a good guy but he's going
to go home he's going to tell everybody
where I live so I called another
locksmith out to him and said I need all
my locks changed the thing about your
typical pin and Tumble locks the ones
you have like what is it I think it's
five numbers so uh I'm not an expert on
this but my general understanding is
that
there's the grooves correlate with
numbers and if you know the numbers you
can cut the key so it so a locksmith for
instance when you when you call a
locksmith and then he you know sticks
the key in and then he marks it and does
it again and then he creates a key to
open the door he knows the numbers of
your key and can recreate it pretty
easily not to mention I just gotta be
honest you guys the lock on your door
if you really think that's keeping
anybody around like obviously for one
someone could kick a door in very easily
very true but there's things called bump
Keys which are basically filed down to
the lowest point and you just tap it in
and turn it it pops right open there's
also uh rakes and locksmiths tend to use
like a I think it's called a rate gun
it's just a it's a device you stick in
and you and you pull it you pull it and
it Jiggles the pins until it pops open
really easy to get access to that's why
you need a gun you gotta defend yourself
that's why you need it done let's jump
to the story from the Daily Mail we're
gonna talk about that parallel economy
Bill Gates bets on Bud Lights come back
as Tech Mogul buys 1.7 million shares of
disgraced Brands parent company it's so
serious that the Daily Mail put Three
L's in million uh after the Dylan
Mulvaney partnership
the Microsoft founder acquired the Bud
Light shares via his Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation trust during the second
quarter of this year the shares hold a
market value of approximately 95 million
dollars reports tip ranks
my friends
we stand before us a great opportunity
if we
convince everyone not to drink Bud Light
and double down on the boycott not only
will you teach a local Corporation a
lesson a corporation that keeps doubling
down on this messaging despite the
backlash you will drive
you will you will take money away from
Bill Gates the shares that he purchased
will go down in value and he will lose
money grant that's only 95 million
dollars you know and if this drops by a
couple bucks he's going to go down to
like 90. he's not really going to Blink
the dudes worth 100 plus billion dollars
but uh you know whatever one can dream
it's a victory for you not for not a
loss for him
but this is this is it you know
obviously I'm not surprised to see this
from Bill Gates this to me seems more
like Bill Gates is trying to save the
stock price of Anheuser-Busch yeah this
purchase is going to stabilize the price
to a certain degree or perhaps even
create the perception it's recovering in
an attempt to manipulate people who
don't care about the culture wars into
buying the stocks again or the shares
and then that will cause more people to
want to be involved
I say
don't let them do it don't let them do
it I'm not gonna give you Financial
advice I'm just saying like from a
culture cultural perspective we have to
double down on the on the Bud Light
story once again the fact that Bill
Gates just bought a large portion of it
is all the more reason to absolutely
reject Bud Light as a product
what percentage did he get out of that
oh it's microscopic in terms of
anhyzer's you know
what is it they say Bud Light shares
that's probably you know a b inbev
not necessarily in in Bud Light or in uh
Budweiser yeah they say Bud Light stock
but I'm pretty sure that it's actually
shares an anhyzer which is a b inbev
yeah I mean I don't think we have
anything to worry about a lot of people
are still not buying but like yeah but
Bud Light to hire the Dasani guy because
nobody buys Dasani water then we just
get them to lose money you buy Dasani
water yes we found the one person
have you ever seen those pictures like
Florida and after a hurricane like all
the water's gone except for the Dasani
Waters all just sitting there you're the
one guy yeah well they like I love stuff
in it
I like Dasani and I like Aquafina I
bought both of them I bought one pack of
Dasani one pack Aquafina well but let's
let's talk about this parallel economy
right so outside of what you know Bill
Gates may want to do you've got
conservative dads Ultra right beer uh
this is uh Southwest we've got a bunch
of the his beer we ordered it it's it's
it's good stuff and uh they're doing
sales by the by the truckload it's crazy
apparently they're doing ridiculously
well
you take a look at the failures of these
companies when they get woke and go
broke and uh on in this story we have
the Amazing Story of a young man who had
one dream and now to sell pancakes
before I said that was my American Dream
all level one it was freedom and
pancakes so uh let's let's talk about
your pancakes though because this is a
big component of building this parallel
economy I want to say
I was personally deeply offended when
they took Aunt Jemima away because when
I was little we had Aunt Jemima all the
time I'd go downstairs I'd grab the box
I I would never follow the instructions
I would just pour the mix into the into
the cup I'd mix it with a little bit of
milk or something and then just throw in
the pan with too much butter so it got
fried and you know ridiculous and
delicious and then I grew up on that and
like we're not racist my family we we
liked the brand it was we had Aunt
Jemima syrup and then one day they
decided it was not okay for for people
for anybody to smile and look up to an
iconic figure on a product that was
black Uncle Ben Aunt Jemima and and Mrs
Butterworth oh not even black they took
anyone who was black off of products
they're the Lakes ladies there was a guy
on Cream of Wheat too it's a black guy
on the cream of wheat that was good they
took him off the Box they took him off
of his product also what what is that
guy's name on the cream of wheat I think
it was awesome yeah Frank L white yeah
they took this guy off the box also that
that but but like I said earlier it's
insane because these same people who
were upset that a black face was on a
food box are the same people who say
black people need more representation
but if you go into the grocery store now
you don't see any black people on any
food boxes at all
Rd yeah he's still there the Quaker Oats
guy he's still there Quaker Oats is
Happy ass he's happier he is happy as
hell and he is happy as hell he's like
hell yeah that's a religious thing too
he's a Quaker yeah this is what bothered
me is that like
imagine you go to a restaurant every day
and
they're like you go to you go for
breakfast before work and there's Aunt
Jemima making your pancakes smiling
she's a good friend she's always there
you know that when you're having a rough
day you show up and she's got a smile on
her face and delicious pancakes and then
one day the boss is like we got rid of
her because we can have a black person
working here it's racist that's
basically what they did the iconic
images of these of these characters I I
just thought like like who like how were
you losing sleep at night because it's
black woman was on a pancake box like
who was sitting up at night uh rolling
over in bed can't sleep and they uh oh
this like that's bothering you check it
out the family got mad yes because they
were getting paid I guess oh no multiple
because multiple women have portrayed on
my men in history and that's it this is
yeah this is the craziest thing I heard
they said
so they're claiming that Aunt Jemima is
like some slave figure and they're
saying that white people get a kick out
of this black woman making them pancakes
it's like she's like a house slave in
the home of like in in in in the home of
white people so they really didn't want
white people uh having this black
character on a food box in their cabinet
it's this was she a slave no she was not
a slave but they said she's a
spokesperson but they're saying that she
is like a slave figure like a like like
a house slave so that's what they were
trying to claim but it's ridiculous I
have not met one person who wanted this
woman off of the box I want to meet the
people yeah I want to meet these people
I want to meet your mama herself and
then you and put yourself on then
exactly and listen like Aunt jemama any
time that I had Aunt Jemima I was I mean
extremely happy and you know and I was
introduced to Aunt Jemima when I was
growing up when I was growing up in uh
foster care one of my foster homes all
they bought was Aunt Jemima uh pancakes
so I was introduced to her and I just
fell in love with that man six so and
every time I see that box it brings back
memories from childhood and then they
took it away so I was like what the like
what in the hell you should see if the
company will sell it will sell you the
trademark the thing about it they would
never do that they would no but they've
abandoned it you might be able to just
take it that's like like you were
talking about it's a logo for
Independence yeah no because no they are
still using it if you now they're not
using her face but they're using the
name on the new box it's Pearl Milling
Company no they're used no if you if you
see the box at the very bottom it says
uh uh it says um
uh uh same taste that's not your mama so
they're still using but they're still
using this wrong man but you still might
have a legal challenge to the trademark
because yeah they've changed it so we
have this right here this is uh Tim cast
skateboard company which I announced
several months ago and and independent
has no challenge this symbol right here
is is uh it used to be the independent
skateboard trucks logo and they
abandoned it because people said it
looks like a German Iron Cross or
something and it's it's racist or
whatever so they apologize no we're not
racist they got rid of that logo
and so I said okay then it's a it's
abandoned IP it's now public domain I'm
using it
so I could try I could try and you know
one thing that all Americans most of us
have in common white white people black
people Hispanics all Americans most
Americans love pancakes and if they
don't love pancakes they love waffles
you know and and that's one thing that
would bring people together is food
pancakes waffles or french toast
pancakes pancakes pancakes use different
kinds of flour
uh do I use different almond flour do
you ever no I I do not have almond flour
but I am coming out with a with a vegan
mix how's that work how's what's the
ingredients no buttermilk it's gonna be
but like uh vanilla bean
um and then I have a keto mix that'll
come out soon and also I have
gluten-free at the moment what's the
gluten-free the gluten-free how do you
make it yeah uh man it's so many
different ingredients but yeah I I need
to read all the ingredients yeah yeah
flowers yeah
um
but it's uh and then I have like
different flavors I have uh uh you know
like blueberry apple cinnamon cinnamon
bun oh wow um chocolate chip you know
and yeah oh what was the other one
chocolate chip uh yeah so I have
chocolate chip and uh sweet potato mix
pumpkin spice I have a whole bunch of
different mixes but I need to find out
you know the gluten-free stuff is
gluten-free certified so anything I say
on here I have to get it right yeah
they'll be breathing down my back freeze
where it's at yeah sometimes but how I
feel about that pumpkin spice one but
the rest of it you know you're you're in
uh what do you say 38 stores yeah so I'm
in yes I'm in the Sedano Supermarket
it's in South Florida how do we get
cousin teas so you wide in every
Supermarket oh man getting these so so
many so many of the grocery stores are
so woke and you know and this is the
tough thing here so you know cousin T's
now people can get it on cousin
tease.com right now
um uh so I ship everywhere but you know
I'm still I'm a small business and uh
what it cost me to make my pancake mix
the big brands are selling it for what I
for what like there's the the price that
they're selling it at is a price that
I'm buying it at because they buy
millions of boxes to drive their costs
down I don't have the money to do that
right so in the grocery stores they like
to mark up the products 30 to 40 percent
well my product is already it it's all
right it's it's already expensive
premium yeah compared to and it's a
gourmet product too so it is more
expensive compared to the bigger Brands
um so you know if you put my stuff on
the Shelf it's going to be way more
expensive because the grocery stores
market up 30 or 40. so that's so that's
so so that's what I'm dealing with too
and all also Walmart is so woke Target
is woke and they like I said anytime I
try to get into these stores they they
go they most likely they look at my
social media account they say no we
can't take it they don't return my
emails
calling them racist
you just need people to go to the
manager store and be like you guys carry
cousin tees and if they're like no I'll
be like are you is there are you ever
gonna get it in I love that stuff and
then eventually stores will be like call
your local grocery store and request it
yeah and you know and people people have
done that
who call Sedano super
call sadonna
calling me uh uh uh uh terence's
Insurrection is and he's Terence is uh
he's racist and he's this and he's that
and they and they have attempted to try
to give me booted out of that store but
thank God that they haven't you know
paid that any mind at all so you know
and sedanos is a Cuban it's it's a it's
a Cuban chain you know and I really
appreciate my Cubans we feel that I
would love to be everywhere else we
filmed the commercial earlier yeah we
did yeah cash Brewing cousin T's yeah
cath Brew some really great coffee yeah
really great we have the same issue
right it's more expensive because we
only do like a couple hundred bags at a
time and then it takes like six weeks or
whatever or it takes ten so the bag
printing takes a long time because we
want the bags to be like good we want
the product to be good made in America
and all that stuff and uh I'd love to
get to the point where we could drive
costs down by buying Millions upon
Millions but we'll get there we're not
in any stores we just have the online
store we're launching our own coffee
shop which should be open in a couple of
months but this is what matters let the
woke companies get what go broke it may
be more difficult but that's the point
if it was easy it would just be the way
that's the saying right right we don't
take shortcuts
if your if cousin T's becomes big and
takes over then you've got a company
like Aunt Jemima which used to be a
staple I'd go to the corner store down
the street and that's all they had if
you're buying pancake mix It's that or
you could buy Bisquick but you got to
add stuff to Bisquick and jimine was
ready to go out of the box as a little
kid I can just mix it with water and I
got pancakes well let them be woke and
we won't buy from them I'm not saying
everybody can do this and this is why I
like when you said as a care package a
lot of people ask me about the cousin
T's Original Syrup and it says no high
fructose corn sup but immediately I had
someone say ah but that's not real maple
syrup and I'm like well dude do you
think the average family is gonna drop
20 bucks on pure refrigerated perishable
maple syrup exactly or do they want
something closer to what they can afford
to buy which is the lower cost but you
also have pure maple syrup I also
exactly I sell both I'll give people the
option because some people cannot afford
pure Maple that pure Maple cost me a lot
of money it's like 20 bucks when you buy
it in those glass bottles yes but also
there's no high fructose corn syrup in
your uh exactly yeah exactly and the
Original Syrup is very delicious but
everybody can't afford a a 16 20 bottle
of pair of pure maple syrup so I offer
The Original Syrup and then people like
oh well it's not real okay then go I
also have the real syrup too right so
what you're going to go so what you're
going to complain about now you know but
I but I I do think we have to start
supporting uh these non-woke companies
like cast crew coffee cousin teas or
cast Brew blue
that's so cool dude yeah yes yeah we
yeah we really have to so that's what
I'm doing like I found a company on on
uh Public Square I'm coming out with
jellies are you in Public Square yes I'm
all yes I'm on Public Square and I saw a
company that like so I'm coming out with
some with some jellies and jams and I
saw a company I think it's called
Laurel's butter and she sell all kinds
of like peanut butter and like the like
the butter is all different like almond
butter pea like peanut like peanut
butter but uh butter made with sunflower
seeds and all different kind of flavors
like pancake flavor butter I mean some
really great stuff so instead of me you
know coming out with my own butter I
said you know what I'm gonna do I
reached out to that company and said I
want to do a collaboration you know I
want to do a collaboration you know we
can sell our items to like together I'm
gonna try your product and and if I
think it's great then you know I will
help you out and that's what I'm gonna
do and then and if I get a call to the
grocery store like if I get a meeting at
like if I get a meeting at uh at some
grocery store chain and you know what
I'm gonna do if there's a great company
that I think that is a great fit I'm a
hey so there's this company called
Laurel's uh butter a company called cast
Brew Coffee they have some really great
coffee can I bring in the samples
because we all we all work together so I
can bring you yeah gluten-free right
here yeah exactly yeah
but that's what but that's what we have
to do you know how bad was the pushback
when when you said you said people were
you said when I came out with the
pancake mix okay I it was so since so
you know since I've done comedy some
people thought it was a joke they
thought it was a parody but you know and
that's what I was low-key afraid of is
that some people may not take it serious
because they think it's a joke but it
ended up but it ended up you know
blowing up and people love it
um but then you had but then I had
haters calling it Uncle Tom cakes
cakes wow yeah you know and saying oh
you are disgraced oh you're a copycat oh
uh Aunt jemama should sue you look at
your smile you're smiling like her
that's copyright infringement I'm like
what are y'all talking about you're
smiling like I'm just yeah exactly it's
a copyright infringement I own my this
is my smile God gave me this smile you
know like what what are you talking
about but yeah I got a lot of pushback
and a lot of people were uh uh uh
talking crap about it trying to put out
fake putting you and that's what they do
too they go to the reviews and put fake
reviews they leave fake reviews and I
and I mean just but if I was a liberal
this is a crazy thing if I was a black
liberal those same black people and
those same liberals they would be all
this is black Excellence oh this is
black Excellence Terence come from
foster care and now he has his own food
company I would be on MSNBC CNN I would
be on The View I will be on Good Morning
America this is uh the greatest success
story this Terrance group in foster care
and he you know for the first uh 15
years of of of of of his life and he has
his own pancake company and uh they
would have been doing all of that but
since I am a a conservative a trump
supporter uh it all like my story
doesn't matter Terence is trash
terence's a sellout he's selling out his
uh he's selling out his community and
he's whitewashed and I I just think it's
bogus because y'all claim y'all y'all
always talking about oh black people
need more opportunities in America
that's all I hear black people need more
opportunities the the white man needs to
give black uh they need to give black
people a chance here I am black I'm
black like this is I'm blind black black
blackity black you know
um and and those same and those same
people don't support me because I think
differently you think if you ever have
you ever considered so it is Hypocrites
like being apolitical to sell more
products or is that just hell no no no
and no not at not at all like before I
even uh came out and said I was gonna
support Trump
I told one of my family members you know
I was talking about me blowing up on
social media people have been asking me
who like who uh who uh who who am I
going to vote for and I said
um president Trump no I said Trump at
the time because he wasn't the president
I said Trump they said hell no do not do
that because you want to be a comedian
you want to be an actor you will never
make it in Hollywood if you come out
supporting him because people don't like
him they they think he's racist like
they think he's racist and I was laying
I was laying I was laying in bed
thinking like you know what
it didn't feel right for me to just to
hold back and not share I I am so
opinionated and for me to suppress my
opinion and to and to pretend to be
something that I'm not pretend and
pretend to believe in something that I
don't believe in it's just it just
didn't sit right with me it doesn't it
didn't feel right so I said forget it
like I support president Trump and I am
aware before I and I was aware before I
said that that guess what I may not be
allowed in Hollywood if I ever want to
be a comedian if I ever want to be an
actor I won't get the I won't get the
gig but I don't care because I feel good
I was able to say what I wanted to say I
feel free
I feel free when I when I'm able to
express my opinion and I don't give a
damn what people say anymore I don't
care and I was surprised in the
beginning because a lot of my friends
attacked me
um I had family members calling me
joking around at Thanksgiving Uncle Tom
I'm I'm getting them a side eye
like you know like shut the f up like
come on like don't do not start with me
I'm not bringing up Trump I'm not
bringing up politics so don't you bring
it up but I was I I was taken back by so
many people that I grew up with that I
went to school with attacking me telling
me I better not show up to the class
reunion or I'm gonna get my ass beat uh
if they ever see me in uh in uh in uh
Oklahoma again because I'm from Oklahoma
City but I live in Texas now if I ever
seen you in Oklahoma again we gonna like
we're gonna We gonna we're gonna shoot
you or we gonna beat you up we're gonna
we're gonna slap the crap out of you I'm
like wow these are people that are these
are people that I broke rare these are
people that I'm that I invited to to my
house to my apartment you know these are
people that that I gave money to because
the little money that I had you know
making 20 or 30 000 a year being a line
cook and you know these are people that
I helped when I didn't even have the
money to help people and all of a sudden
I'm a bad guy I'm this horrible
whitewash Uncle Tom so I said but
you know what I didn't let that hold me
back and I kept going at it I didn't
give a damn did you any of those your
friends that kind of turned on you I
don't know how you describe it I assume
it was in text that they yeah text
message did they because
we were not going to be face face to
face you threatening me I'm I'm not
facing you face to face you get a chance
to work through with any of those guys
or people no not at all not at all once
you call me a name once you call me a
name or Uncle Tom a you you call me
a sellout there's no working it out when
me I'm not going to explain myself to
you and I'm not going to apologize for
thinking differently I'm not going to
apologize for voting for some individual
I'm not going to do that so no I will
I'm not working it out and I don't reach
out to them now I had a sibling one of
my siblings I've been working it out
with him but I have been keeping
distance from him but you know and
throughout the years since 2016 if I
don't give him money because he you know
if he like they think I'm just some
multi-millionaire because I have
hundreds and thousands of like millions
of followers or whatever but if I don't
give them money or whatever one of my
siblings he calls me Uncle Tom and
you you like you know you're a b-i-t-c-h
and you whitewash you ain't nothing but
a sellout you know I just ignore that
but since we are siblings you know I I
you know I said them straight listen
like it's stop texting me you know like
but you know but we go crabs in a barrel
yeah exactly but yeah I just at the end
of the day I'm not letting anybody bully
me like you are not about to bully me
call me what you want I don't give a
damn I got thick skin and and it it is
what it is are you yeah are you in
Austin I mean I used to live in Austin
oh yeah uh but I live in Houston now do
you ever work at the mothership Rogan's
comedy club no I haven't no that'd be
funny as hell dude I moved before that
uh before he uh opened that up there
yeah I'd like to see her stand up yeah
do you is it online I haven't seen it
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah oh hey I got the
ingredients of the gluten-free mix I
checked it out it's a bunch of different
kinds of flour there's corn flour yeah
long grain rice flour potato starch and
tapioca starch with whole oat flour and
actually whole sorghum flour sorghum's
pretty cool yeah but uh the the general
idea here for everybody's listening is
uh
we have to we have to challenge this
woke cult economy it's not easy it will
be hard but it's gonna be worth it when
you look at what happens with the Bud
Light and everybody not everybody 30 of
their customers are like I got no
problem not buying your beer and I'll
buy from somebody else in order for it
to to happen there has to be
Alternatives with Bud Light Miller and
Coors are readily available and of
course Miller and Coors are also
partially woke in their own way Miller
cores or whatever uh but they did not go
as far with Bud Light then Bud Light
insulted their customers
cousin tease is an alternative you know
right right so so don't if you're buying
pancake mix there's no reason to buy
pearl Milling Company exactly garbage
companies that are that are
condescending insulting and I wonder if
they're running they did it and I'm I'm
also you know and I'm growing slowly but
I'm also uh I'm also expanding the brand
I'm coming out with rice
you know coming out with rice and I'm
putting my black face on there too yes
so they came out to Uncle like uh Uncle
Ben but the rice has been difficult
because I don't have the money some of
these rice companies you got to buy one
million pounds yeah that is the minimum
I'm like ah I can't do that
but yeah exactly I need that
distribution but I'm coming out with all
kind of food like I'm coming out with
different fruit products like oatmeal
peanut butter biscuits uh I'm I'm gonna
collaborate with a Public Square company
yeah instead of coming out with my own
butter I'm a collaborate I want to start
helping other food companies I don't
have to compete with every food company
on Public Square I want us to come
together and help each other so that's
what I'm gonna start doing you know
instead of you know instead of trying to
instead of spending a bunch of money
trying to come out with a new product
here and a new product there I don't
have to come out with every single
product you know I can work with with a
like-minded company and help them and we
can we can we can collaborate and be a
family brand so you know where we start
maybe it's going to be really difficult
to get in these big chain supermarkets
but I'm sure a lot of people listen to
the show have small shops corner stores
cafes or whatever even gas stations the
gas station down the street is really
funny a month ago I went in there and
they had an original Aunt Jemima box and
I'm like wow so I bought it that was a
while ago that was like two years ago
they got rid of it that box has been
sitting there for a long time yeah but
there's no reason that they don't
carrying cousin teas inside Aunt jemimas
it's just an issue of people listening
to the show knowing and then deciding to
reach out to you and then say like give
us a wholesale price and then we'll sell
it at our store and that's and that's
how we do we've got people hitting us up
for Casper coffee saying like can we
carry your coffee can we get like
wholesale pricing and we're like done
and my attitude right now is dude
we'll make it the best deal in the world
for you because we just want to uh for
us
I'm not I'm not trying I'm not I'm not
disrupting the coffee industry the way
you are but like you know Aunt Jemima
plays as BS yeah you know and they get
rid of edge of my mother become Pro
million company you come out with your
face on it for us we're trying to open a
physical Coffee location so that people
can come together hang out and then we
can build community and then we can set
up awesome a bunch of these chains all
over the place so people who share our
views and values and even disagree
politically but respect the truth and
cut the constitutional republic we live
in you know that there's a place you can
go to where there's going to be
like-minded individuals and drunk a cup
of coffee watching you know TV or
watching a show
we can put TVs on the walls that play
Crowder play Jimmy Dore play yeah you're
like you know Terence Williams comedy
stuff can be playing on the TV that's
our goal so for me I'm like building the
brand and getting it out there is the
most important thing granted
the fastest way towards establishing a
thousand locations is making money doing
it but you got to find that immediately
exactly are your website sales crushing
cousin yeah it's uh you can go to cousin
tease.com I'm looking at it now it's
answer my or not so right now I have
over a hundred thousand customers
Shopify gave me an award whoa yeah they
gave me an award for having a hundred
thousand customers wow yeah so how long
have you been around for uh I started
the company October of 2021. wow that's
when I started selling the thing is this
I remember that the the pancakes are
good yeah now I don't care how much
Somebody Loves You if your food is not
good they're not gonna buy it again so
people come back and buy but you know
um and a lot of it in the beginning was
organic sales I've been running you know
uh ads on Facebook and these are ads
that I make in like at home on my like
on my cell phone but I talked to rumble
because I want to stop spending money
with Facebook I want to stop spending ad
money with them because you guys have
demonetized me
my my account is is in the red uh I
can't do this and I can't do that but
you still take my money to run ads
but I'm so but I'm so bad that I can't
that that my account has been flagged
you know you got me marked as hate
speech but I'm not that hateful because
you're taking my money
and and you're taking my money so that I
can Market to the people who follow me
and I just think that's wrong like so I
might as well so I was you know I talked
to rumble like hey I want to start
running ads with Rumble because they're
not gonna mark my account as hate speech
and and like so and uh suppress me we
got to get some of your cousin t's for
our event in Miami oh yeah oh yeah I saw
that with what yeah with Patrick David
yeah we're gonna be we're we have a
bunch of bags that are being everyone
who comes also gets a bag of products
that I don't know exactly what it's
going to be but we're we're taking
samples from different Public Square
companies okay and then as an attendee
you get a bag and it's going to have a
bunch of stuff oh that's pretty awesome
yeah that's pretty awesome but we're
also selling Casper coffee there so
people can buy it when you're there yeah
and we have a whole bunch just came in
and uh we should just we should do the
same thing with cousin T's I don't know
if we end up with you know adults but if
I have a dozen of them yeah I mean I
don't mind giving out some free pancakes
you know because once they try
they are going to want to buy another
box yeah the ingredients are good so I'm
very confident you know compared to
Pearl Milling Company ingredients which
is like bleached flour yeah oh it's just
so much so much gross yeah so I have
unbleached flour yeah what's the
difference
uh bleaching on bleached is just it's
it's it's it's more Gourmet it's like
it's just as described it's bleached or
not yeah it's bleached or not that's
actually niacinamide reduced iron
thiamine mono nuts
and the pancakes are just vitamins dude
yeah well that's what they say but the
thing is about vitamins if you get it if
you eat a fruit and it has a vitamin in
it it's different than isolating the
um vitamin and adding it on top of a
piece of meat and eating it your body's
going to synthesize it differently so
you can't just shove a bunch of stuff on
top of your food and expect it but you
got protein in yours too I was impressed
like buttermilk and stuff yeah so I I
tried it for the first time today and it
was yeah now you I was actually going to
come out with a protein mix you know I
paid this great graphic designer to come
up with with the design spend a lot of
money on it but it's the protein mix is
gonna have to wait and I did tell my I
did tell a bunch of my customers that it
was coming out this year but
unfortunately it I cannot launch it
because one box of the of a buttermilk
protein box a 16 ounce box is going to
cost me almost five dollars
and then I have to pay a handling fee I
have to pay you know a distribution
center to pick and pack my so it's going
to be too expensive for the for the
consumer so I'm gonna just wait on that
but it will come soon though it will
come through your private company I
would imagine yes do you have any
intention of taking it public and taking
Investments and things like that yes I
do yes I do
um and actually I like what Tim was
talking about opening up a physical
local location oh dude so I am actually
yeah can we can we open a cousin T's
breakfast most definitely I was just I
was just talking to I was just talking
to some people about that opening up a
cousin tea shop you know because I'm not
going to be begging these stores to take
me forever but I'm not saying the shop
I'm saying a diner you come and sit down
and yeah yeah yeah I know yeah I know
and but I'm also sell the product in the
diner you know so people can come in and
eat and they can buy boxes of Pancakes
and so yeah I got we gotta we gotta do
this and the other thing we're trying to
do is Papa Jack's Pizza Shack which is
you know Jack besobics Pizza Hut
nationalism bit oh no I don't he talks
about how back in the day Pizza Hut was
his family sit down restaurant with a
salad bar and the commercials were like
family get-togethers that have parties
you'd get the book it little thing where
you'd come and you know you if you do
the book report you can come and it was
now it's it's like a strip mall hole in
the wall with like 100 square feet where
you walk in order pizza and leave or
it's delivery
all we see now are these abandoned Pizza
Hut buildings and there's that that Meme
like no matter what they put there you
know it's a Pizza Hut you know it was
and now it's gone
so I told Jack I'm like bro we gotta
open Papa Jack's Pizza Shack like we
gotta make it happen and we could the
only issue is we need someone to do it
yeah like Jack and I are both like yes
and we're always making jokes and he was
like the entrance is a big gate yeah so
it's a gate so there's so there is this
outspoken celebrity chef named Andrew
girl he's been on the show of course
yeah yeah I mean this guy has I mean
he's this guy built up a restaurant and
sold it you know friends
he has to play he can do it Andrew girl
knows what like what he's doing and I am
and I have talked to him too so I think
that's somebody that we should talk to
is Andrew girl because he started slap
fish and he build it out you know and he
sold all these franchises and then he
and yeah so uh I think it's called slap
fish is it I don't know it's called
Slapfish but he taught me how to make
eggs yeah but vinegar his but his but
his Slapfish he sold it they are in
airports they have you know tons of tons
of low of of uh of uh locations so I
think Andrew Grill will be a great guy
to work with you know
here's what I'm imagining
if we can find a location like a
building that has two fronts and one we
do the cousin T's breakfast and one is
Papa Jack's Pizza Shack two birds with
one stone yeah everyone's gonna want to
go to both everyone's gonna show up this
is this is the plan we got to do this
yeah we should do this you know the uh
the red cups from people yeah I have
some the old red plastic cups I got them
on eBay
a true man I remember the salad bar yep
man decorated with kale their crust was
always too greasy for me but now
compared to Domino's Pizza's crust has
Splenda in it oh it's it's it's awful
Splenda in their crust why they put
Splenda in it makes it sweet I guess and
you Papa John's is actually really good
Papa John's and Little Caesars uh their
ingredients are pretty good but this is
what I'm talking about family friendly
family themed sit down pizza restaurant
we gotta do it cousin T's breakfast yeah
brunch yeah right yeah chicken and
waffles
it's like obviously a full service yeah
exactly yeah yeah people would love that
people will love it and they have that
beautiful that Beauty look at that face
yeah a big sign out there that big old
smiley face
it's like shining sunlight right behind
they're gonna say I have to try that you
look so happy I have to go to that place
we gotta we gotta hit up uh Chef gruel
yeah Chef girl yeah because I'm sure he
is the guy he is the guy do it follow
him on Twitter he is the guy yeah he's
cool oh this is gonna be he has built
restaurants and sold them so he knows
what he's doing CEO executive chef of
slap fish that's the company you're
talking about earlier casual seafood
restaurant and it was a franchise too
right yep and he made it a franchise and
he sold several and he's he he's he sold
the company and made a lot of money and
he has more restaurants this is the way
all right we'll hit him up in the
meantime we're gonna go to super chats
so if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends if you really do like it because
word of mouth is the best way to help
podcasts grow it's how they all grow
there's no there's no real advertising
you can do it's just you guys if you
like the show sharing it but head over
to timcast.com click join us to become a
member and you'll get access to the
uncensored members only show which is
coming up at about 10 p.m and as members
you can submit questions and actually
call into the show so we look forward to
hearing from you but let's read your
super chats Ben says did I beat him yes
Ben you were the first Super chat today
uh you win you win
um
a compliment good job
purple says your boy Luke went in better
than Tucker asked Larry if he was on
coke live LMFAO cast Brew for Life rip
Roberto Jr appreciate it man did the guy
say no that he wasn't on coke I didn't I
didn't see it but I did see Luke posted
the picture where he's holding up the
sign saying it was like at the airport
yeah I'm not gonna that's a funny one
Jay says in Starfield I saw the pronouns
and character creation and my first
thought was oh the modders will deal
with that in no time I don't stream so
no one will know and thus no soapboxing
the pronoun punks will grow up
eventually so apparently what I was told
is the game goes out of its way to
create scenarios where your pronouns are
used in front of you which typically
doesn't happen in the real world like
we're here having a conversation in what
context would I be talking to Ian and
talking about Ian and say he
instead of just his name or or you
because it's second person
apparently I was told that they create
scenarios where you will be in a
conversation then two people will start
talking to each other and they'll be
like so how did this happen it'll go he
did it but it's like but you're in the
conversation you'd use their name so
it's like they're trying to make
pronouns growing up I was taught that
that's rude if you're in the room with
somebody you do not use he or she you
use their name right yeah so did you see
the as is rant as from heal versus
Babyface where he just breaks he just
goes on this two and a half minute ramp
i i i skimmed it yeah it was uh you
didn't like Starfield he just didn't
like the the all the the major
amalgamation of all of these things just
beating him down and he's basically just
saying he's like look it's very modern
day it's very California and have you
played Baldur's game no it's worse no
it's you can't get away from me in any
form of media it's like what's going on
right now is everyone's like it's kind
of like how you're talking about whether
you're talking about building culture
you can only you can't only watch Daily
wire movies so like we like people say
why'd you go watch these movies why do
you go do this stuff this year in my
opinion outside of some bed the crap
from Disney I didn't find most of the
movies this year to be all that awful
expensive notice there's some really
good actors coming up like things are
starting to change I'm starting to see
Talent either it's in me or people
really are waking up and it doesn't mean
that the industry is good or that these
companies are companies that you should
like but I'm just saying that it's it's
there's the game seemed worse for a lot
of people I mean I went to the movies I
went to go the other day I went to see
equal uh but Denzel is a great guy
though you have to I love Denzel
Washington your favorite actor of all
time best actress on Earth yeah it's in
that and that one's good that's a that's
a good movie too yeah let's read let's
read some more we got uh Marion Holtzman
says I met Terence really nice guy I
also bought his pancake mix so light and
fluffy they're great I just want to eat
a big sack of pancakes right now all
right Tech says I have an old Aunt
Jemima bottle I'm just gonna refill with
Sam's Club Maple as a statement I'm
gonna buy some cousin teas soon though
right on thank you thank you is she just
out of work the uh whoever they use most
recently for her face that's an old it
was a family were they not getting like
they got cut off they were yeah they got
cut off so the more I think about this
and the more you guys have discussed
this tonight I'm like okay they don't
want to pay her they used the summer of
love as yeah just as an excuse just to
fire those families it doesn't explain
Mrs butterworths it doesn't explain
Uncle Ben
yeah I love that one they got rid of the
Native American but they kept the land
yep
classic
his uncle a man actually a slave no he
wasn't
they have an issue which is weird I'm
telling you now with these black uh um
okay the thing is this the people who
bought the people who bought Aunt jemama
out and Uncle Ben are their own they
were owned by these big corporations
that are ran by uh uh white people you
know and uh people have them they're
like well these white people own these
these black Brands and I think people
are thinking in their heads these white
people get a kick out of
you know these black people on these
food boxes as if they're cooking for
them in their home it's so it's okay but
also they're profiting from it yes yes
and they're profiting from it yeah if I
woke up at some point yeah and I smell
delicious pancakes and maple syrup and
cinnamon or whatever and I ran
downstairs and Aunt Becky was making
pancakes there's no issue whatsoever
that Aunt Becky made me pancakes but if
it's a black woman all of a sudden now
it's racist yeah that's racist exactly
that that really really was shockingly
offensive to me because you know I grew
up with just like it's your friendly
Aunt Jemima your family member who loves
you and cares about you and has cooked
you pancakes exactly and they're like
nah you're not allowed to have black
friends or family members we're getting
rid of that it's like so many families
gathered around the table to eat on your
mama's pancakes and had a lot of people
have memories like when they see that
box they think of their childhood
memories you know and yeah yeah enough
now it's cousins because now people
gotta you know got kids you should buy a
box of this and you should wake your
kids up in the morning with fresh hot
pancakes with butter and syrup and the
cousin T's box is right there and I'll
be damned if they try to take my face
off they can't because I mean they got
to get me to do it like
you made the company it's your company
exactly exactly mad at you about it yeah
exactly yeah we're gonna try to buy you
out just to just to shut it down yeah
yeah
all right yeah Kane Abel says Trump does
need to win but we need more than just
him we need regular people
constitutionalists to replace the unit
party run for office and replace the
rhinos and Democrats in every race
agreed we need local uh people running
in for local office we need to know who
our local reps are Tim Wolf was in it
yeah never that's right I don't I agree
with the Super Chat I don't want to do
it but that's a problem I don't want to
serve my country as a political officer
right now I just don't want to but I do
yeah I do think people should start
holding the people in office right now
accountable I I see too many people uh
uh saying stuff like hey Tim Poole you
should be doing more Terrence are are uh
uh uh JP Sears or David Harris or yeah
Lord yeah you guys should be doing more
have that same energy with Kevin
McCarthy he's the one running he's the
one running a show right now you know
like
here's the thing too it's like yo you're
producing content all the time you're
speaking out all the time and you
launched a company to challenge a woke
brand
we we produce a show I do a Morning Show
nightly show hey look man we're doing a
lot
I don't expect anyone else to do
anything except the bare minimum right
that means if you're somebody who's
watching and you're thinking what can I
do oh it's really easy you just got to
stop buying Pearl Milling Company
pancakes and Bud Light that's the
easiest thing ever just by cousin T's in
casparu and then you're helping support
the work we do and you're helping us
expand I'll tell you like you're talking
about all the products you're going to
be launching and expanding into the
purpose of what we're doing with Casper
is not because we're trying to make a
ton of money it's because we want to
replace woke coffee shops that are
putting up all the weird pride month
stuff and just have family community
oriented uh small businesses I'll put it
this way it's like
I'm hoping that Casper will be like
Chick-fil-A but for coffee Chick-fil-A
is a franchise but you're only allowed
to own one of them we don't want a
corporation starting opening 100
franchises and then you get bad quality
and weird corporate policies and none of
that none of that the purpose of this is
that families can come they know that
when they do come here there's not going
to be any weird creepy inappropriate
stuff no adult performances for kids
there's never going to be cartoons
playing that have weird creepy stuff
like mastectomy scars you know that if
you come in on Saturday morning when we
do our Saturday morning cartoons events
this is what we're doing I'll tell you
this we were the plan with this coffee
shop and why we want to do it comes from
what I call Saturday morning cartoons
where and this is inspired by Jack the
sovik Saturday morning 7 A.M the family
comes in they bring their kids there's a
breakfast buffet the kids watch approved
family cartoons cartoons like we used to
watch with good messaging and none of
the weird stuff you're saying today like
the Blues Clues mastectomy scars thing
yeah and this is for five year olds it's
ridiculous the parents socialize they
meet each other they build community
with each other they have breakfast they
break bread kids meet each other the
kids socialize you build community you
know in a way that churches used to do
and and if people want to go to church
they should keep doing it but this is
for a lot of people who are missing that
and we'll have cousin T's pancakes when
we do it awesome so but but this is the
goal I'm hoping that when we launch
these coffee shops not only
do you have the busy businesswoman on
her way to a business lunch saying I
need to grab a coffee before before the
meeting pull up on Google Maps the
coffee shop pops up in a strip mall she
comes in to Casper coffee she's she's
buying a drink and on the TV Steven
Crowder's playing and so she's hearing
him Play a clip from Joe Biden doing
something and now she knows having that
physical cultural uh penetration that's
what I'm hoping for Casper that's why
we're doing it so the bare minimum for
everybody is
watch down to Freedom listen to Richmond
north of Richmond don't buy Bud Light
shop at uh download Public Square it's
the easiest thing in the world to just
be like all I have to do is buy a
different thing yeah and that's the bare
minimum you can do more you can register
people to vote you can look up uh uh you
know speech political initiatives in
terms of uh advocating for policy or
volunteering with with politicians you
believe in or something like that but
really the bare minimum is this parallel
economy and Shifting the cultural
narrative and taking the power away from
these institutions that are woke and
trying to poison the mind of our kids in
the Next Generation start a channel and
speak your mind with internet video it's
freaking so powerful and it's relatively
cheap or or get get people to sign up
for twit for X this is the this is the
big one
instead of trying to convince people
you're right and arguing about it say to
them oh I'm not familiar with that you
should are you on X can you send it to
me and then when they're like I'm not
like oh well sign in and then DM me that
video I didn't see that now these people
are signing up and they're getting
exposed to information they don't get
through the corporate press no but you
know now Elon did mention uh that uh uh
very soon you don't even have to have an
account you can you can send people a
link to whatever and they can watch it
you don't even like he's not an account
without an account you're going to have
access to to see things on X logged out
viewership viewership that makes sense I
mean if you have the app you can curate
a list of people to follow without being
without signing up for the app yeah I
always thought it was a greedy tactic
when developers like no you have to log
in to see anything and I get the greed
like we need people to log in because it
improves our numbers outward facing and
then we'll get more investment people
take us more seriously but reality is I
mean you're going to get 10 times more
views exactly let's read some more Papa
Romano says Terence do we have a
discount code for tonight stepping up
your game with that chocolate chip mix I
bought a bunch of Christmas gifts it was
a hit well there isn't purchasing on
either way well there's actually a
discount code on the website right now
it's one on Public Square though right
yeah and it's one on Public Square you
can use discount code uh cousin 20 for
20 off
um
um and there's also a discount code
that's on the website it's still a Labor
Day code well I'll tell you what it's
really easy download Public Square
search for sign up search for cousin
teas and you will see they have a
specific discount code but uh I'm not
going to say it because I want you to
download Public Square dude I love
Public Square so much they're sponsoring
our show in Miami they're awesome dudes
and this is this is the winningest thing
ever it's all of these brands
I mean look at this they got a picture
of pancakes right on the front page and
he just did it see for dude he just was
like it's happening well the best part
the best part about Public Square and
you can use code USA 25 just go to
cousin tease.com and there's a discount
code on there yeah so USA 25 cousin
cousin 20 you can use public uh Square
20 yeah yeah I was gonna say the best
part about Public Square is like forget
about the wokeness for a second like I
don't know if I'm even connected to any
of the brands I'm purchasing at the
grocery store I don't know who owns them
I don't know who started them I don't
know the backstory like it's probably a
better idea to actually know the
backstory and know that hey you're the
guy behind cousin team's brand it's like
I don't know who's behind Aunt jemimas
like I know she's the face of the
product before they changed it but who
started it it's part of Revelation man
we're we're revealing who runs these
companies that's what apocalypse means
it means Revelation means new knowledge
let's uh let's read some more Lars says
Cornell West sounded like a Biden
supporter today on Jimmy Dore Jimmy
never looked so disappointed
that's a bummer
oh man
all right Patrick Bannon says the view
is really only on in jail that's one of
the shows black men and women in jail
watch not many younger people watch TV
anymore is that true about playing I
would be surprised to be honest
did you see that CNN is trying let that
Warner Brothers is thinking about
putting CNN push-ups like push
notifications on maps oh god oh can you
imagine you're you're trying to watch
Doctor Who or something and then there's
just some CNN propaganda that just
flashes nobody wants to watch CNN they
force and they are forcing that that
channel on to people yeah you know just
like at the airports they kill me with
it it's gone seeing it everywhere it's
all going out yeah oh thank God thank
God all right what do we got
see Keegan mazus's first time superchat
a long time viewer you inspired me to
start a sub stack consider this a job
application an article that I wrote
actually sparked a local protest in New
Hampshire where the police barred
citizens from entering a public library
wow crazy man see that's the influence
you can have when you speak out we've
got big news coming soon
um we're relaunching scnr and AKA
subverse so anybody who invested in that
the company has never ceased it has just
been dealing with legal issues and um
will resume really really soon we're
constantly working on the background on
uh procedural
um software and um policy but we're
we're getting ready to relaunch
everything and we're really excited for
what's to come so uh
fear not and for a lot of people they're
upset they were like why aren't you
saying what's happening with it it was a
lawsuit we were literally barred from
talking about it like there's nothing I
can do and it's crazy because people are
pissed off they're like we we invested
in this and it's like dude I there's
like there's there's literally no
response it's like you're in a lawsuit
you're not allowed to talk about it's
like okay but good news is it's kicking
back up and um we got some really big
info really big updates coming soon and
I'm really excited for that so it's
gonna be really fun Marion Holtzman says
Liberty Safe just Budweiser themselves
Brendan Dilly talked about it today on
his show
yeah well you know it's unfortunate I
don't even care about
um the the politics of it it's like
there's a back door
Baron of gray matter says you guys are
ridiculous Liberty saves back panel acts
as user changeable you buy the safe
change the default code it is secure
come on use your head the argument is
that the code was changed and they had a
back door code to the machine
I suppose it's possible
that the guy bought it with the default
code and never inputted it or never
changed anything which I really doubt or
the it's sent that the new password to
the company the moral of the story is is
a Liberty Safe shouldn't have gave the
FBI access not without a court order not
without a court order yeah
yep yeah I don't know if he's saying
that there's two
like pads on this safe because he's
saying a back panel but either way yeah
you because your Safe Company should not
have any type of access to once you buy
it that's yours to protect your property
if the argument is that a dude bought a
safe and left the default code there and
the company just knew his code
they shouldn't have given it in the
first place they should wait for a court
order but in that regard then you're
dealing with it's the person at fault
however it would seem they said their
policy is to give up the codes if there
is a warrant that makes it seem the the
the Occam's razor is they have a back
door to these machines which is it's not
atypical it's something companies
companies do look at this uh Joel
McKinney says all saves do this because
people die is that because people could
get locked inside of them or something
no I think they mean that the sole owner
of the password is gonna die one day and
then you can't I think that's too bad
similar with social media accounts I
wonder because no one has my data for
like any of my social media accounts but
I see people they're like
I mean if the owner dies I mean if he
didn't if he didn't if he didn't write
down the codes for his family he didn't
want them to have in the first place
barium with the safe yeah yeah if
they're if you have if you have an old
school safe with a combination or a key
just no knows where it is well that's
too bad I don't I don't see why you
create a back door I can see the safety
thing if it's like a huge industrial
safe like for whatever like the seed
Vault that might have a back door you
know just in case someone gets trapped
in there Elijah Butterfield says I used
to work for Liberty Safe down in Payson
Utah it's in let's just say awful
company really they work their employees
and prison workers like robots for low
wages the same day I left was the same
day some guy got broken in half because
an 800 pound safe felony I always assume
I always thought he died I am dude so
they use prison labor
I don't know low-key the people who run
the company they were probably happy to
give those codes to the FBI they were
probably happy to see someone get locked
up for January 6. probably more prison
labor for them keyword probably
so weird all right Jon Jones says hi
Terence just ordered some of your
Original Syrup and pancake mix can't
wait to try it thank you John thank you
right on
beautiful bacon says I just put in an
order for cousin T's pancake mix and
pure maple syrup looking forward to a
delicious breakfast in my near future
cheers Terence keep rocking them brother
you know what I think we should thank
you all so much but y'all gonna have to
stop telling Tim this Tim gonna send me
an invoice
your pancakes mix is selling out on the
website y'all please is it yeah cousin
T's buttermilk two pack is sold out yeah
and the four packs also sold out what
get your cousin tease now well I'm about
to go update it because you know these
blueberries are available that looks
good blueberry Gourmet and they need the
six pack still up 40 but
earlier the uh the four pack was sold
out and the other one wasn't so it just
sold out yeah that's because the
inventory levels were not uh updated
open it up so if you did sell out would
you just still take the orders and then
just put them on back order no so I have
plenty of Pancakes so I know how much
was on there and we're not out oh good
it just needs to be updated and I'm
doing that right here on my phone nice
dude right here being a business owner
is fun everybody listen Terence is
challenging you he claims that you can't
sell out his invite he can't sell his
inventory you gotta prove him wrong
buy all of his pancakes good ingredients
hey look man uh
I want I want cousin T's to take over I
want to see them in every Supermarket I
want these woke corporations to know
that when they play dirty games they win
they win stupid prizes so if they want
to if they want to insult us if they
want to lie to us if they want to
manipulate us we can easily find through
beautiful capitalism Alternatives yep
dude Terence do you make the like the
recipes yourself or do you work with
people that are really good at it and
yeah so I work with the manufacturing
company out in New York so they helped
me come up with the mix you tell them
like I'm looking for a blueberry yeah
yeah I want Gourmet I try it out hey can
you help me you know I'm not in the lab
myself you know because I'm not a food
scientist that'd be a funny video if
you're going to the lab yeah I'm not in
the lab myself
we're trying to do what I really really
want is an MCT powder protein powder mix
so after uh before after an exercise I'm
getting whey which is you know readily
available bioavailability whatever and
MCT for energy and typically you can get
one of the other the problem we run into
is we go to these companies that do
sourcing and all of their General
products have awful stuff in them really
nasty stuff and so we're like okay
I don't I'm I'm not interested in
Splenda or whatever sucralose in
anything I'm eating I wouldn't sell that
yeah it's challenging there's a lot of
people who will eat garbage and don't
care and you know you want to make
something that you believe in that you
want and it's harder to get or it's more
expensive and then it's like man some
people can't afford it so that's one of
the things holding us back from doing
protein is that oh we can do as a small
company if we do our own formulations
it's it's expensive like you were saying
yeah it is and if we want to do the like
bulk cheaper numbers then you're getting
weird preservatives and splend on stuff
and I'm like can we not do that and
they're like oh but then you got to do a
proprietary formulation in the lab yeah
and that small batch hard to produce and
very expensive and you know what's crazy
is you know I mean I've done so much
research some labs and uh uh
some manufacturing companies they will
not let you they will not let you own
the ingredients they like they will they
they will do whatever you want they'll
customize it they will put they will
make whatever they will make whatever
recipe you you want but they like to
hold on to it so you need so you keep
coming back to them buying it and buying
it some of them don't want to do a
one-time fee of like ten thousand
dollars no we want Tim to keep buying
this powder from us right we no we own
the ingredients yes you pick them all
out but we're but we put it together and
we want to keep it you know so they keep
the ingredients on site with them yeah
basically you don't really sometimes
they don't some of these manufacturing
companies they don't want you to own it
here's what we got to do yeah the recipe
yeah they want they want to keep it for
themselves so they keep because let's
say let's say you're selling millions of
boxes they can make more money by you
continuing to buy like buying batches
from them instead of you instead of them
taking a one-time fee so we we're
opening the Casper coffee shop and it
should be we're we're hoping that maybe
by just after Halloween we're getting
delayed because regulations and stuff
like we got to fix certain things and
then you fix one thing and they're like
oh wait you gotta fix that thing but how
cool would it be if you've got a cast
Brew Coffee you got a cousin T's
breakfast shop and a Papa Jack's Pizza
Shack all right there
24 7 man and then we create a strip in a
city with all these businesses as the
launching pad it'll be like a tourist
attraction basically you know what it
can be done we're doing it it can be
done it can be done easily I mean
especially around here nothing is
impossible we're gonna make it happen
nothing is impossible since you said
it's a franchise to have like whoever
starts the franchise implement the local
culture into it somehow you know like if
in Texas yeah maybe the employees wear
cowboy hats and then no that's the first
silly thing off the top of their head
that's that's stereotypical but very
offensive to Texas 10 gallon man but no
no but like you know it is annoying to
go to Starbucks and it's like every
single one is the exact same uh I just
you know you like that I think man I
think that's good because you could have
some crazy uh person who buys a
franchise and and they don't and it's
just they don't all kinds of stuff there
you don't like but but sure yeah we we
go out we're driving around and I'm like
I would like some coffee I like coffee
with heavy cream in it Starbucks is
basically the only place ever that has
it and there's some small cafes you get
lucky I know that if I go to Starbucks
they're gonna have it I don't like
Starbucks as a massive multinational
corporation right I'd rather support a
mom and pop shop so I'll typically make
that choice out here we've got a woke
coffee shop and a Starbucks so I go to
Starbucks instead yeah yeah you're right
about the heavy cream because you know
when I was doing keto
um my coffee was heavy cream and some
splint some uh some uh monk fruit or
Stevia yeah yeah that's what I love so
also I want to give a shout out to uh
Jocko jacko's Mulk best protein powder
I've ever had it's it's monk fruit
sweetened it's it's super delicious
there's no garbage in it I'm super
impressed and a big fan of Jocko so
super cool that he's doing some
something good and healthy I'm a big fan
but uh if you haven't already my friend
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and become a member by going to
timcast.com clicking join us the members
only uncensored show will be starting up
in just a few minutes at timcast.com you
don't want to miss it you can follow the
show at timcast IRL everywhere follow at
timcast news on on X and you can follow
me personally at timcast Terence you
want to shout anything else out so you
can go to cousin tees.com and get some
pancakes and syrup and use the discount
code uh usa25 is a discount code on the
website or Public Square 20 or uh and
you can watch my podcast on Rumble the
Terence K Williams podcast and you can
watch it on YouTube too but you know
they may not update you when my podcast
come out but you know so yeah thank
y'all so much thank you Tim
right on all right uh guys if you want
to follow me you can follow me on Twix
that's better than Twitter or X Twix and
Instagram at Brett dasific on both of
those platforms uh me and Mary do pop
culture crisis Monday through Friday 3
P.M Eastern Standard Time that is noon
Pacific right here on YouTube come hang
out with us uh Terrace you got a book I
just found on cousin T's you can also
purchase it oh yeah so uh Tim I need to
actually I'm gonna send all y'all a book
the book is called from The Foster House
to the White House and it's just a book
about me going it's a book about me
going through foster care and uh about
everything like that I went through and
overcame and and then going to the White
House to meet president Trump now the
book is not political but you know it's
it's about the American dream and and
I'm and I and the book came out in 2020
but the book is still for sale and I
hope it inspires a lot of foster kids
and all Americans all around the world
all around America thanks for making us
bomb us pancakes
catch you later brother Terence Williams
ladies and gentlemen uh what's up
everybody you guys can follow me at
Kellen PDL oh man I'm hungry I need to
get some of those pancakes I'm jealous
that you guys got to have them earlier I
just had a small bite to be honest still
it's good they look good but yeah thanks
guys all right everybody we'll see you
all over at timcast.com in a few minutes
thanks for hanging out